that's the EP calling me what
television let's not carried away here
Joy behar's living proof that anything
can happen on live TV it's unreal it
always is on The View she's wrapped up
plenty of on-air mishaps many of them
because of her cell phone oh my God turn
it off
oh you know stop it
and why does Siri talk to me in the
middle of nowhere it's either I don't
understand what you're saying it's like
who's talking to you I'm not talking to
you Brian I'm sorry that's Joy
apologizing to Brian tedda the talk show
Staples executive producer I have no
control over technology who decides to
poke fun at the comedian's trademark
faux pas on Tuesday calling her while
the ladies gab about the Hot Topic cell
phone etiquette I almost should recuse
myself from this conversation because I
am such an addict as you know woman
that's true but I would say and I don't
care when people use their phones at
dinner I don't really doesn't bother me
at all
right now that's the EP calling me what
well I've had a lot of therapy and
that's what you need at the view of
course Joy is not the only panelist with
tech issues when we start to conflate
sexuality and gender a lot of the issues
coming up right now are a
misunderstanding and ignorance
[Laughter]
your watch is interrupted oh my gosh
something answered I you guys nothing's
I don't know what's going on here
back in May Sarah tried to silence her
phone by sitting on it and it got us
thinking of this accident last year
which led to production giving the
ladies some better chairs The Following
season come on just stop just stand it's
happened to all of us at 185 years that
has never happened
[Applause]
we know who we are didn't we try to do
the best we can and for Whoopi doing
their best includes no screen time at
the table it's the adults who are the
issues the adults who are the problem
everybody's got their phone I don't
carry it because I'm here an hour you
can wait now out we can wait we'll be
right back
if you're not entertaining people they
will turn you off
[Music]